ich kann gar nicht mehr schlagen oder
der musterküchen freuen und herzlich
willkommen zurück sondern weiteren folge
minecraft galaxy gestern kam kein galaxy
sollte eigentlich noch ein stunden voll
gekommen allerdings nachdem diese einen
starken allerdings nachdem dieses eine
mal dass abgestürzt das erstmal hajo
gedreht nachdem das eine mal da
irgendwie abgestürzt ist ist hier so
einiges passiert und zwar konnte ich
dann teilweise ich gar nicht auf den
server
dann habe ich versucht im singleplayer
so ein bisschen zu spielen ging dann
auch nicht wollte ich den launch
allgemein mars starten und mein
kompletter tag auf der b2d installiert
ich habe dann in der gruppe die wir
dafür haben erstmal richtig richtig viel
herumgerutscht so dass mir immer leute
weiterhelfen sollte man da kann keiner
mehr
jedenfalls habe ich alles wieder richtig
gebogen und ich möchte aber nicht zu
wissen hier
ich weiß nicht ob ich morgen schaffe
oder so aber eventuell kommt dann morgen
die ein stunden folge und noch ein
anderes video
wenn ich es ganz alles zeitlich schaffe
dann sollte das sogar richtig morgen
kommen die ein stunden folge weil jetzt
klappt ja auch alles jetzt ist ja alles
gerade perfekt
ich wollte nämlich in diesen stunden
voll geladen sein paar sachen machen die
die farm nach unten verlegen habe ich
eigentlich vorgeschlagen allerdings
werde ich das ganze jetzt machen
ich werde in der ein stunden folge sache
machen wie noch mehr fossilien
raussuchen versuchen wir dann wirklich
ein dino zu zähmen und möbel machen und
in dieser folge werde ich die farmer
nach unten packen das werde ich ganz
kurz mal abfahren das ganze hier und
dann auch das ist hier sogar alles noch
im wachsen hier die ganze kg
da kann das alles gar nicht gewachsen
naja egal ich möchte ganz erfahren wir
auf jeden fall nach unten teleportieren
damit ich hier oben mal so ein bisschen
platz hat irgendwas vernünftiges hier zu
bauen also ich habe ja quasi immer nur
diese ganze farben hier in meinem meinem
eingangsbereich hier drin gehabt und das
finde ich nicht so cool das fand ich ja
auch nicht so cool deswegen geld nicht
mehr jetzt daraus ein paar wasser einmal
neben das noch was kommen hier hab ich
ja mal wasser allem ich glaube plänen
habe ich den habe ich nicht ich hab den
ja ich habe mich doch hier
da sind wir da so ein bisschen wasser
hallo nicht mehr so ein bisschen wasser
raus sagt zack zack und während ich dann
dass hier gleich alles mal so ein
bisschen hier wegpacken was ist da los
keine ahnung wer diesen los hier werde
ich euch ein bisschen was erzählen was
die letzten tage so gemacht habe und
zwar
ich gästen am nürburgring und hab da das
24 stunden rennen geschaut
davor war ich in köln weil das e auf dem
weg liegt wenn ich zum nürburgring fahre
habe ich aber mit niemandem getroffen
aber ich habe ein paar sachen in köln
gesehen ich habe passanten gefilmt und
ich habe allgemein sehr viel diese woche
gefilmt was tier
ich weiß nicht ob ich heute noch schaffe
hochzuladen aber im kontakt auf jeden
fall sehen werdet wenn schon kommt heute
abend etwas später da wir hatten mal
eine ganze woche sehen also das ist dann
irgendwie eine woche in meinem leben
oder irgendwie sowas
den hat das ja von einem tag gemacht ich
hab gedacht ich mach das mal von einer
woche das ist wirklich das ist keine de
wirft das nicht weg sind dass es keine
typische woche in meinem leben so wie
sie jede woche stattfindet sondern das
ist einfach mal eine woche aus meinem
leben rausgepickt und da kommt jetzt
vielleicht auch schon eine sache die ich
euch mal fragen wollte wo ihr bitte ganz
ganz viel in die kommentare dazu
schreibt oder man einfach den daumen
hoch gibt wenn ihr das wollt dass ich
öfters rihanna videos mache
bei mir ist es oft so die kontakte wenn
ich mich auf einen tag festlege und ihr
seht es aber bei den fans dann kommt
teilweise die fans kommen ist es immer
am mittwoch ist dienstags nicht schaffe
und auch die kontakte kommen als das
montags oder teilweise echt gar nicht
weil ich dann einfach keine zeit dafür
habe die sache ist einfach dass das
ganze mich so ein bisschen nicht
nachrichten vom staat falsch ein und ich
will den fehler muss das entstehen das
liegt nicht irgendwie daran dass ich da
dann keine lust von farbe sondern dass
sie entweder keine zeit habe oder dass
ich gerade nichts passendes habe oder
zuviel passendes habe beispielsweise in
dieser woche ist mir aufgefallen ich
habe jetzt einfach mal alles gefilmt was
dieser woche gemacht hätte ich ja doch
alles einfach so ja komm das ist meine
woche dass der kontakt dann hätte ich
auch in extra video machen können ja
komm ich bin jetzt am nürburgring oder
extra wiederkommen ich zuletzt in köln
hier bleibe ich da so viele sachen
einfach gefilmt haben deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht dass ich einfach in zukunft
also der konter kommt diesmal das hätte
ich in kontakt auch nochmal euch fragen
weil diese folge vielleicht es gibt
leute die nur die raelert videos von mir
schauen werde ich das so machen dass ich
einfach öfters raelert videos mache und
mich da nicht diesen kontakt auf einen
sonntag festlegen werde sondern dass ich
einfach videos mache wenn ich quasi bock
darauf haben weil es ist manchmal einer
woche so habe ich mittwoch eine tolle
idee von kontakt- und der kontakt ist
dann quasi auf sonntag festgelegt und
dann habe ich donnerstags noch eine gute
idee und samstags fahren noch in wien
nach london oder so wir haben das
städtereise oder sowas dann habe ich
quasi drei sachen die ich in einem
kontakt machen kann wo ich eigentlich
drei videos machen kann und dass jedes
thema dann besser behandelt wird in den
drei videos da bin ich zurzeit aber
überlegen wie ich das ganze mache dann
bin ich auf eure hilfe nicht angewiesen
aber ich wäre froh wenn ich mir dann die
zweite hälfte würde weil der kanal
gehört nicht mir sondern der gehört
eigentlich nur euch weil ihr das alles
hier anschaut und wenn ihr das nicht
anschauen würde dann wäre es ja quasi
kein kanal also keine ahnung was ich
kann glaube aber sollte das alles
bestimmen dürfen was ich mache und ich
habe dann einfach gedacht das kann auch
mal sein dass der woche gar kein wähler
video kommt das kann aber auch mal sein
dass eine woche fünf videos kommen wo
ich einfach dann beispielsweise in der
nächsten woche also was als nächste
woche morgen morgen fliege ich für einen
tag nach london hinflug ist morgens um
sechs uhr abends fliege ich um 19 uhr
zurück und einfach so eine städtereise
verein tragen weil mittlerweile ich habe
jetzt mit abi ich habe sehr viel frei
und deswegen möchte das ganze einfach
mal ausnutzen jetzt ein bisschen so die
welt der kunde ich war zwar schon
viermal in london
aber ich meine letzte mal so ein
erlebnis dann könnte ich auch 50.000 mal
hinfahren das ist einfach die schönste
stadt der welt finde ich
nach hamburg und an dritter stelle steht
köln finde ich in letzter zeit auch so
auf den köln mit auch wenn ich in
hamburg drohne werde ich wahrscheinlich
selbst auf nach köln fahren einfach
wegen netzwerk wegen auch weil ich mit
felix noch also mit rot pilz wollte ich
wakeboarden irgendwie alles möglich da
werden wir auch gute sachen für film und
jedenfalls keine ahnung ich fahre auf
jeden fall nach london und da werde ich
richtig viel film und das wird
wahrscheinlich ein ganzes video download
zu london sein
und das wäre zu schade wenn ich das
casino und im kontakt mal so eben
erwähnen würde ja ich habe nur noch ein
paar sachen gefühl er würde ich gern
sein komplettes video zu machen
deswegen möchte ich da gerne eure
meinung wissen hören was was euch da
interessiert was nicht was euch
interessiert sondern was ihr davon
haltet wenn ich sondern das ganze
einfach so ein bisschen ja was heißt
trainer also also ein bisschen sauer
kommen heute ist zwar sonntag aber es
muss nicht nur video kommen sondern
beispielsweise an einem montag auch soja
kommen heute ist am montag deutlich
kommt heute kein kontakt weil eigentlich
am sonntag kommt aber dann kommt da doch
manuela video weil ich da beispielsweise
gerade auf jeden oldtimer messe in
düsseldorf war und dann dass du das
gemacht aber so ein beispiel
aber so was wie beispiel sein wenn ich
am nürburgring bin und echt extrem viele
sache da gefilmt habe dann kommt das war
heute noch wenn ich schaffe alles
zusammen in einem video meine ganze
woche aber dann in zukunft wenn ich das
dann so eine einzelne videos packen dann
habt ihr einerseits mehr videos und
andererseits habt ihr das ganze so ein
bisschen sortierter stadt ist nur für
euch ich kann doch alles in einige
packen aber ich glaube ich als zuschauer
das nicht so gut war ich in letzter zeit
so viele youtuber schauer die einfach so
[Musik]
weiß nicht diese ihren nicht ja die film
so ihren ganzen tag und laden das für
jeden tag hoch da ich mir okay
der kontakt war anfangs darauf ausgelegt
dass ich ich möchte ihnen was grün ist
noch gar nicht am rot grün
ich hab nur quantum ich habe doch habe
ich nicht in den in den in denn dein
gehirn nicht was es da ja richtig viel
wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen in so ein
paar sachen muss noch ein bisschen kohle
rein da sollten wir nicht da ist auch
gut dass noch kohle dann packe ich
moment da noch ein bisschen so dich
[Musik]
da auch noch so ein bisschen
dann kann ich daraus jedenfalls ich
leute die wirklich den ganzen tag film
und ich denke es war für euch cooler und
auch für mich cool wenn das ganze nicht
so untergeht in einem kontakt sondern
das ganze ein bisschen eigenständiger
wird die serielle die austria kommt wenn
real love kommt wenn ich bock drauf hat
beispielsweise so nach dem motto wenn
euch das gefällt dann zeigt mir bitte
einfach wirklich mit einem daumen hoch
weil das ist die einfachste funktionen
dieser ganzen kommentare das sind zwar
super wenn ihr eure meinung äußern
wollte aber wenn er sagt ja nicht gut da
gibt den daumen hoch und wenn der sagt
nicht gut dann schreibt diesmal einfach
alle dann kann ich sehen okay gut das
ist der grund warum es nicht wollte bock
moment denke aber eigentlich das meist
nichts dagegen haben wären wir ja quasi
hatte ich einfach mehr räder videos
kommen das ganze heißt nicht dass mein
kanal komplett realisiert weil ich sehe
ich wieder kommen
du machst du doch wer live videos gar
kein minecraft mehr
das wird er wieder häufig in den
kommentaren stehen und java ist nicht
stimmt halt einfach nicht ich will immer
noch weiter mein kraft machen weil es
mir spaß macht aber nicht dass da so ein
paar leute dann denken sowohl fakt der
macht ja nur noch dies und dies dann
wollen wir doch gar nicht
ich mache schon mal in kraft nur so ein
bisschen mehr den fokus nicht den fokus
obwohl das ist auch wieder falsch ein
bisschen noch da steht ein vorwand
so ein bisschen das ganze ich weiß nicht
wie ich das nennen soll bisschen nicht
mehr ist ist ja nicht mal mehr wie live
videos ist einfach nur grüner kombi
nicht bock hat und ich musste dann nicht
an den tag richten ich brauche eine
spitzhacke ich wollte irgendwas grüns
waren aber ich bin nicht grün ist dann
machen wir das gleiche einfach auf warf
ihr dann brauche ich noch ein bisschen
sticks oder die folge ist auch gleich
wieder vorbei blablabla
also ein kleiner plant für morgen ich
bin morgen in london wird dann
wahrscheinlich auf instagram wo mir
immer noch nicht ja da folgen wir zwar
als 70.000 leute aber in den videos
fragen mich immer noch leute höhe bist
du wirklich der kontrast auf instagram
nein bin ich nicht ich heiße dort laser
luca das steht in jedem video in der
beschreibung
da werde ich sehr viele posten denke ich
morgen wenn ich in dortmund bin nach
dortmund was lava ich denke ich bin in
london
das habe ich dann von dortmund man man
man wenn ich in london bin werde ich
sehr viel bei instagram posten und bei
twitter
weil da gibt es manchmal so free wifi
und so und naja dann können wir da
theoretisch folgen wenn ihr wollt nur
wenn ihr wollt und dann kommt morgen
wenn ich alles gut planen
ein video wo ich über ein thema reden
also da kommt eine pvp runde monster
grad black der kommt eine pvp runde wo
die als hintergrund ist und dabei werde
ich beim thema reden was mich seit
langem beschäftigt was nichts mit mir zu
tun hat sondern mit dem internet
allgemein sehr sehr krasses thema also
das wird auf jeden fall ziemlich horror
mäßig sein
das ist einfach sehr krass das werde ich
wahrscheinlich morgen machen warum höre
ich das jetzt überhaupt schon of
scotland eigentlich quasi gar nicht mehr
dazu ich muss schauen wie ich dass die
allgemeinen jetzt noch alles mache etwas
wo ich schon sehr lange darüber reden
will was sehr sehr mäßig wirklich
angehaucht ist das ist ein sehr sehr
krasses treptow ja da will ich auf jeden
fall darüber reden in der pvp runde die
als hintergrund dazu kommt und dann
kommt höchstwahrscheinlich abends dann
hat die ein stunden folge weil wenn ich
morgens um sechs oder mein flug nehme
dann lade ich die folge hoch da liegt
die sieben stunden lang hoch oder das
ist perfekt dann sollte das eigentlich
alles klappen
ich habe die farbe auf jeden fall schon
mal weg gekriegt dieser folge das freut
mich schon mal
ich bin jetzt nicht so sicher wie weit
ich das noch bauen soll in die wand rein
weil er da auch schon wieder hier andere
leute ein leben muss man einmal
nachdenken was ich alles mache ich hab'
ich habe schon gedacht hier einfach mal
in meinen kisten stauraum zu machen
aber es ist auch ein bisschen blöd dass
ich das hier so auch gemacht habe da das
sollte eigentlich houellebecq ist ein
bisschen weil sie nicht hier kommen auf
jeden fall noch so einen zaun hin
ich höre ändern in sachen
er ist vom laut vw in rom ist gut alles
gut
dann kommt hier noch so ein grober
fehler hin dann habe ich das ja auch mal
am besten weg und war damit besser
aussieht ob es vielleicht einfach mal
runter hier kommt auch alle weg es regt
mich ja oft dass das da oben so blöd
gebaut ist moment da kommt so ein cooler
feiler hin den ich aus diesem holz
hierbei eigentlich wollte in dieser
folge auf ein paar möbel machen aber ich
denke dass man alles in den stunden
folge so dann kommt ihr hier
dann sieht das schon mal so abgetrennt
was dann kommt hier meine kisten wandten
und die ganzen öfen und alles mögliche
patrick läuft hat hallo gesagt das
arschloch der minimal hallo gesagt und
tablets zu bleiben da hängen jedoch die
konsumiert dann kommt da so eine
ich weiß nicht aus welchem material ist
dass bauern war schauen
und der dino der wächst auch immer mehr
ne moment sogar stellen keinen mund
[Musik]
geschlagen
ich kann gar nicht mehr schlagen oder
denkst oh wow machst das schon viel
schaden kleiner mann
jetzt macht er schon ein herz boa wieder
auf ein mal ausrastet erschrocken des
todes friedman ich fühle cooleren die
nur als den mann na ja ich würde sagen
haben nichts geschafft wir haben dass
die fahrer ein bisschen weg geräumt und
hier kommt jetzt auch noch alles aus
holz damit das ganze ein bisschen
schöner in der stunde folge werde ich
möbel bauen
ich werde mich wenn ich schaffe ein
bisschen mit tinkers construct
beschäftigen wenn ich schaffe und sonst
wird das ganze dann hier viel viel
schöner gemacht und dann würde ich sagen
wenn es euch gefallen hat lasst doch
bitte eine bewertung da meine axt schon
mal so ein bisschen aber ich glaube das
ist nur wegen dem mondlicht sehr sehr
cool
märz euch gefallen hat das bewährte
unterschreiben dass auf jeden fall mit
den reha videos den konter kommt nachher
noch wenn ich es schaffe
und tschüss